all right quick reminder before we dive
into this live episode we had a special
guest on this one and boy does he make
us seem silly most of the time like he's
he's really profound and I always hate
bringing people like Joshua Becker on
the stage with us yeah he I run the
surprise maybe shock him bleep that out
yes
leave out Joshua Becker's name no he he
is great he just answers questions
masterfully and yes every time it's like
I feel the same way like when we were on
stage was rob bell it's like people like
that we bring on stage and they're there
other you know upstaging us not
intentionally and I am asking myself why
did I bring this person on stage you can
mix us so much better make me sound like
an idiot no I totally agree dude I was
so happy to have him yeah and oh it's
also a reminder this is the last day to
support our packed bags project you can
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash bag you can see the bag that we
use when we travel but as always we want
to discourage you from buying this bag
unless you absolutely need it you don't
need to just consume on impulse you can
find out for yourself whether you
actually need it whether it will truly
add value to your life you can watch the
the trailer that we put together you can
see us traveling with it over at the
minimalists comm slash bag and also
we're on the road right now we're
finishing up the less is now tour in
North America we're gonna be in Detroit
Milwaukee and loss of Vegas that Las
Vegas one is a charity event a hundred
percent of the profits go to the Victims
Fund after that terrible mass shooting
that occurred recently and then we're
going in March we're going to be in
Australia and New Zealand most of those
are selling out really quick so get your
tickets while you can the minimalists
calm all right Ryan let's jump into this
episode with Joshua Becker in Phoenix
alright y'all enjoy
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
[Music]
hey y'all let's record a podcast there's
a microphone over here we're start with
like five questions and we'll see what
we can get to after that if possible
we're going to get started I suppose as
long as Sean's good back there you go
John some sort of noise to let me know
we're good
ladies and gentlemen podcast Sean live
from the Mesa Arts Center my name is
Joshua fields Millburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists live in Phoenix
this is so great thank you so much for
being here
before we start diving into some
questions we have a very special guest
here tonight you've actually heard
during the talk earlier you heard both
of us talk about him either directly or
indirectly a really big inspiration when
we were first starting our journey when
I know there are a few things that I
said early on about when I first
approached minimalism there was this
question how might your life be better
with less and I got that question from
the person we're about to bring out on
stage and it was it really made me think
about minimalism in in a different way
and made me think about my life in a
different way and maybe think about my
relationship to stuff because I could
tell you for the longest time the
question I always asked was how my life
be better if I acquired this thing if I
got this promotion if I got more more
MORE and instead what if I were to flip
that around and maybe focus on unless
and then you know Ryan during his talk
he was talking about the various
minimalists that I first introduced him
to and they were living all these
different lives you know there was a guy
like Colin right who was this
peripatetic nomadic writer and like it
was kind of cool and admirable what he
was doing but he was far from a normal
human being personally I like having a
couch and an end table and like he can't
fit that into his backpack so he doesn't
own them and I guess the the the the
person were to bring out here the way
that I when I was showing all these
different minimalist to Ryan like it was
like oh here's an aggressively normal
person who's also a minimalist and man
that was so freeing to me realizing like
you could be a regular person with a
regular family and he lives here locally
as well ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage our good friend
Joshua Becker
I am going to officially add
aggressively normal to every bio I've
ever written about myself it fits right
there in the Twitter bio so you know
it's funny I'm just looking at Josh
right I just realized you couldn't look
like if Josh and I were one person with
the hair it's like if we were combined
we would be Joshua Becker that would be
aggressively actually to add a kid so
early on I stumbled across your website
becoming minimalist calm and and you
have a lot of people there you inspire a
lot of people with your writings you've
written several books most recently a
really great book called the more of
less and yeah yeah it is someone ready
it is a great book and a great audio
book as well so you can check it out in
fact Sean if you can throw a link to
that in the show notes so if people are
listening to this at home and they want
to check it out and they're driving you
don't have to stop and hurt yourself
you'll be able to find it later in in
the show notes to this thing but the
thing that really inspired me actually
at the time you were living in Vermont
sort of in the suburbs and and Ryan
earlier during his talk was talking
about how you had a full-time job and a
car and a house and like contrasting
that with Colin who was just homeless
basically and going to a new country
over four months and and in a situation
that most of us seem so radical that it
felt unstable I saw what you were living
and there's a part in my in my talk
where I'm talking about if you were to
come to my house you wouldn't say oh my
god this guy's a minimalist you probably
just walk in and say he's tidy I'm
actually describing Joshua Becker's
house and in this instance for those of
you haven't you seen our documentary
so you saw Joshua Becker and his wife
Kim and their two kids and the suburbs
of Phoenix and like when I walked in
their house I just felt like calm and I
didn't feel like there was nothing stark
about it it was just really nice to be
there and in welcoming in a way that
wasn't like well what Ryan was talking
about earlier like the the the house
that when he was aspiring to sort of
live in once he could make enough money
to live there when he was a kid I I was
inspired by just walking in there in a
way that was sort of this it was it
wasn't an intellectual exercise it was
like walking in somewhere of a lie I
just felt good about being there and so
when you when you embarked on this
journey it was because you were living a
different type of normal life you were
in the suburbs but maybe not paying
attention to what was most important was
that accurate to say yeah surprisingly
so I think because I I don't think
anyone ever sets out to live a life that
isn't in line with their values or
passions it just it seems like it seems
like society comes along and and almost
hijacks our passions and and begins we
begin spending time and energy and money
on things that you know we we would
never sit down across the table from
someone and say this is what's most
important to me and so surprisingly so
my I was cleaning out my garage on a
Saturday morning and hours later I'm
still working on my garage and my
five-year-old son is swinging alone in
the backyard on the swing set and just
came the realization that everything I
owned wasn't wasn't making me happy but
everything I owned was actually taking
me away from the very things that they
did bring me happiness and purpose and
fulfillment that I'd spent my life you
know chasing and accumulating things
that that weren't in line with my values
and it was it was shocking in the moment
to to come to that to come to that
realization but certainly that was what
that was what
and if I were to add on because because
Colin I met pretty early on finding his
blog as well and I was at you know not
only did he move every four months the
readers of his website voted as to which
country he was going to move to every
four months and I saw
have you considered doing that with your
family no see but that's the point so
there was there was Leo and there was
Colin and uh Logan and Tammy Strobel up
in Portland and moved in this tiny home
and these were all the people that I was
reading reading about and what was
interesting to me was that they were all
they were all pursuing minimalism in
line with what they most valued so Colin
loved traveling and he loved seeing the
world and the struggles couldn't wait to
get out of debt and so they moved to
this tiny home and I just said I like I
like my country I like my I like my
neighborhood I don't want to move every
four months that's not what I want to
get out of minimalism man the fact that
you said such kind things about about my
home that you felt invited and calm and
like like that's what I wanted I mean
that those were the things that were
most important to me and so my my
minimalism was always going to align
with what my values were as opposed to
the others that I was reading and and so
along this journey and one of the things
that that you've I think has been one of
your values and and it's certainly one
of ours is its contribution and so a few
years ago you started a nonprofit called
the HOPE effect and we've been lucky
enough to to be able to partner with you
on a couple of different orphanages that
you're building but it was when you
first came to us you were talking about
the concept it was different from a lot
of other charities because it seemed
much more the word that comes to mind is
intimate I don't know if you would use
that to describe an orphanage but but
building orphanages but can you talk a
little bit about about why you decided
to what the charity is and why you
decided to start it yeah why I started
to start it I may guess there's a long
story my my wife as it was adopted know
a lot of people who have adopted kids
from overseas and just seeing a lot of
different experiences that
we're having actually the the the
nonprofit started out of the more of
less writing writing that book they they
paid me more money than they should have
to write the book and I'm like I'm
writing a book about how we shouldn't
own more stuff well what am I gonna do
with with this author advance so we we
used the we use the the money from the
book to start the nonprofit I'm like
let's go do something meaningful
meaningful with them with the money and
so I guess the the short story behind
the help effect is we've there's there's
like decades worth of research
concerning orphanages institutional
style orphanages the ones that most
people picture with 2030 kids and a few
adults and a couple walls that actually
this style of orphan care in most
developing nations is actually quite
quite harmful for kids that that in
almost every stage of human development
they fall behind and so we had this idea
to build a more of a campus setting we
would build smaller homes in a campus
setting each home would house two
parents and four to six orphans and in
that way it would function like like a
family would they get the intimacy and
attention and affection that they would
in a family and also they just see a
picture of what a family looks like for
when they for when they start one of
their own and so you guys been very
gracious and in supporting that built
built a home in Honduras built not
building our next campus just south of
Yuma on the the us-mexico border has
been in the news a little bit lately so
we are on the Mexico side trying to be
proactive and San Luis Rio Colorado
Mexico is where we're putting our next
campus so thank you guys for your
support and for letting me mention it
here yeah and so if people are listeners
at home or people in the audience are
interested in and find a way to
contribute to that what's what's the
best thing was the best place they can
go to learn more but also what you
encourage them to do yeah sure hope
effect calm is the is the website we use
100% of donations for direct care so
that's the best place beautiful John if
you can put a link to that in the show
notes as well that way people can can
access that as well well mr. Becker have
a we we hang out we we answered
here and then I think we have a few
howdy what's your name and were you from
and then what's your question hopefully
in that order my name is Jennifer and
I'm from Orange County California
welcome thank you
my sister had turned me on to you guys
back in August so I've been listening
since then I'm hooked every week if my
trash cans aren't overly full I'm not
doing it right so for the past eight
weeks I've gotten rid of a lot of stuff
but on the other side of the minimalism
I started my own business about three
years ago and about six months ago I
realized I wasn't happy I wasn't
passionate about it and I sold my
business and it just went into effect
October 1st with a new owner so I'm very
excited it was very stressful a big
weight has been lifted off of me however
I'm finding I have a different kind of
stress sure and so my question is with
you guys
did you ever with what you're doing and
you're passionate about it and living a
more meaningful life do you ever find
that does it ever get completely
stress-free no you know
thanks to the question Jennifer next
question I'm just teasing so let's talk
about that so what what are you stressed
out my guess is this is financial is
that part of it I have a little nest but
it makes me uncomfortable to not have
the income coming in okay that's a good
word uncomfortable so you even listen to
the podcast you program we talk about is
for there three things I really hate
travel public speaking and large crowds
of people i it's not that I hate them I
just find all three of them really
stressful it's not even that they're not
that they're not overly stressful but it
is uncomfortable I feel a sense of
severe discomfort and so much so that I
have to build up certain routines and
rituals and habits so that I can at
least alleviate some of the discomfort
but I also know that that place of
discomfort is the place from which I
grow the most so right now we're you're
what you're feeling
are growing pains okay I I was looking
at Instagram earlier today and I saw
this quote from John Mayer man I'm just
paraphrasing this it's much better if
you go to his Instagram and read it but
it was something along the lines of life
is it is half bitter and half sweet and
it really just hit a chord with me
because I can totally relate with that
it's like I look at what Josh and I are
doing now and it's a lot of work and
it's it is stressful sometimes getting
to the venue on time you miss a flight
and it's like oh my god are we gonna be
even able to like make the show I mean
there's so many things that pop up and
you know to to add to Josh's point of
like no there's a there's never gonna be
no stress like there's always gonna be
some type of stress for me I guess I try
to look at the net the net gain of it
all and if I can look at it and say it's
it's it's net sweet and not net better
then I feel really really good about
what I'm doing and when I do know 100%
is that no matter what I do if I am
focusing on my my values and beliefs the
health and and and having good
relationships and doing something that
that I love creating something
contributing the contribution for me
like giving is living um growing doing
all those things I know that if I focus
on those things I will always I will
always be able to lay my head down on
the pillow and go to sleep
and have a nice night sleep and that is
what I focus on I don't focus on waking
up to you know puppy dogs and rainbows
every morning I don't think that's
realistic honestly in fact if you think
about it like so waking up in an it like
waking up extremely happy if you look at
like an XY graph this is time this is
happiness and on day one you wake up and
you're way up here on the happiness
scale and they - you wake up and you're
here on the happiness scale and then day
three you're here on the happiness scale
and the day for this is called manic and
a lot of manic people that are out
directing traffic right now and they're
not traffic officers and the other thing
too is that that that that bar it gets
that's that's the new norm that becomes
the new norm so I when I have that
stress like I totally accept it because
I understand that it's impossible to
have the peaks without the valleys so
what I would say is embrace the valleys
continue to live up to your values and
beliefs obviously make smart choices but
yes this is a you just got where your
business on October 1st what is what's a
day today I forgot it's week you're in
yeah what's it hello New Jersey no no
III this is absolutely fresh it will get
better but keep making all the smart
choices that you have I promise you it
will be okay but embrace those valleys
because it's it is an important part of
life to accept it okay thank you
Thanks
howdy-hi what you my name is Teresa hey
Teresa and I'm from the San Francisco
area
welcome is everyone here from California
yeah
so I found Joshua Becker
I listened to your audiobook I think
around March and it totally changed my
life I mean it everything then so from
listening to your book which I've
listened to probably three or four times
now because when I run out of a do books
I just listen to that one again
alright enough about Becker you know
with your question and every time I'd go
looking for your blog it would be like
Joshua the minimalist
and you two would always come up so that
I found you guys I'm sorry I'm so sorry
that's where my traffic's going so I do
have a question but the biggest thing
has changed in my life is that shopping
was my sport of choice and there was a
contact sport
I liked better than shopping and now I
hate shopping
like I graduated takes me away from my
kids
that's awesome like yes so I don't want
it I don't want to shop so so that's the
biggest thing I'm so grateful that is
awesome that I don't want to spend money
and I don't want to miss time with my
family so because there's someone out
there right now who loves shopping and
they really want to get over it yeah so
did you just wake up one day and you're
like I don't want to shop anymore no I
had to find I had a formal event to go
to and I needed to buy a dress and I
didn't for one I didn't want to spend
money on a dress that I was only gonna
wear once I live in San Francisco nobody
dresses up took the time would need I
don't need to dress up I didn't need a
fancy dress and I'm in my 40s and all my
friends we all have different bodies it
wasn't something I could
like ask a friend so I had to find a
dress and I spent six hours at the mall
miserable I was just like I don't want
to be here I don't want a new dress I
don't want to be here but I have this
event and I'm going with a family member
and I don't want to embarrass my family
member it's a work thing and I've got to
do this but it sucked so that's and it
really was like I'm leaving in two days
and so I have two days I should be with
my boys right now instead of shopping so
that I can leave for five days so it
took getting some emotional leverage
some pain to really kind of break that
habit right - because it was fun before
when I didn't think about it was fun I
was buying stuff cool I'd get a new
dress hours at the mall yeah they call
that purgatory thank you so much for the
compliment I really appreciate I would I
would just add it's it's it's we would
probably say the same thing that that
there's a moment in time where you begin
pursuing minimalism and it's actually
one of the reasons I think that question
is so important like how would your life
look better with less because when you
see it and when you begin experiencing
it and begin noticing the benefits man I
think the fact that that I was blogging
the fact that you guys were blogging it
just makes us observant - so the changes
they're taking place and what's
happening around us and as we start
noticing how our life is improving in
many ways the the desire to own more
just starts - starts to fade and and you
start seeing the world completely
differently and I I walk into a store
now and I'm like man I don't even like
I'm so happy not wanting all this all
this stuff that I see it's it's it's a
powerful experience to walk into a store
and and not want anything other than the
dress that you need for the party that
you're going
it's so funny you say that man cuz like
we just moved to LA as you know most
people probably know walking around like
it's not just the shops it's the cars
like everywhere I look it's it's a it's
a hundred thousand dollar car it's
unbelievable and I'll tell you my 25
year old self I would have just been
drooling I would have just been like oh
Bailey how can I get myself one of those
Bentley's ER or what I love those
Mercedes Jeeps like they look really
cool I don't know if they're good cars
or not but I like as one of the
minimalists I still look at him like
that's pretty cool I do the same thing
with a big house I'm like that's a
really nice house but that's where it
stops and it's like I can really think
about it and process it and say you know
what I'm not gonna go spend a hundred
thousand dollars on a car you know maybe
I'll spend fifteen thousand bucks on a
car twenty thousand bucks on the car and
I could probably build an orphanage or
two orphanages with the rest of that
money and the fact that we started this
seven years ago like I feel like I
didn't realize it at the time when we
started it but we were just kind of like
conditioning ourselves for LA
interesting thing there because I think
what you're talking about is
appreciation over acquisition and not
needing to acquire the thing in order to
appreciate it like I can yeah some of
those cars look really nice there almost
looks like art in a way but if I go to a
museum I don't want to like take every
painting home that that would be a weird
compulsion but and and a kid and a
consumer culture that's kind of what we
want to do we go to these these museums
called stores and and create this sort
of tomb that we've amassed with stuff
called our homes thanks for coming
I have one quick question I think it's a
direct question so my father passed away
at the beginning of the year and I don't
need his stuff at all I mean I didn't it
wasn't like I was there I didn't have
anything I wanted I had I have him in my
memory but he gave me in the last few
months he gave me some different sort of
religious things little a little charm
thing
which is a nice I keep it it's like a
coin I keep it in my purse
it's nice when I come across it it's
great but recently I came across like a
little cross that sort of opens up it's
about an inch and a half big and it
opens up and you could put little charms
or something in it but I'm like this
this doesn't add value to my life I
don't it's not something I necessarily
want but I'm like but it's a cross and I
don't feel like I could get rid you
don't want to like these sacrilegious
and throw I'm not religious but I'm like
I just it's the real it's the girl and
God and I'm like I'd totally understood
with that um man I don't think I'll
announce publicly what I do with all the
watchtower and awake so that my dad
mails me but but what I'll say is you
don't have to just throw it away you
could absolutely find someone who would
get value out of that but if it's a one
inch cross yeah I'll give you permission
to hang if it's that's it and that's
your one item you're having trouble with
yeah keep it
thank you by the way I just wanted to
say and thank you so much for your
question really really appreciate it
oh when I go so where Mariah and I live
I'll go down to the garage and I still
have the the the 2004 Toyota Corolla
from the documentary like that's our car
and it is by far the shittiest car in
the whole garage and I love it anyway
alright what's your name before we move
on if you're at home and you listen to
this you can give us a call if you have
a comment or tip for anyone who is is
asking us questions today and you'd like
to say something give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or just in a voice mail right no no
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm and it's my favorite
part of the show at the very end we will
air a few comments and tips from our
listeners and it's where I'd continue to
grow and I learn a whole lot of stuff
because you all know some combined know
infinitely more than we do and and so we
get to learn a whole lot at the end of
these episodes so stay tuned for that
Ryan you know what time it is and I
almost forgot it is time for our hashtag
ask the minimalists lightning round
where well we usually answer questions
from social media but it'd be really
weird if we were up here on our phones
looking at Twitter and they we are on
social media at the minimalists on
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
that's where usually answer questions
but I hate some sunflower seeds earlier
and note not to do that before the show
I was back there with Becca earlier and
he was like I was looking at but I
couldn't say any words just because I
had seven different sunflower seeds I
think I'm better now anyway
we're trying to give you a maunder on a
bit but we'll give you a pithy answer we
call the minimal Maxim's and Jessica
Williams who's around here somewhere
she's right there ladies and gentlemen
Jessica Williams
she catalogues all of our pithy answers
over at minimal Maxim's dot-com it's
like just a new users refresh the page
you get a new and yeah yes and she also
live tweets from from the events as well
using the hashtag blesses now from our
account
howdy what's your name weather will give
you it will give you 140 character
answer eventually well I'm not on social
media so that's alright so my name is
Bernie I'm here from Phoenix what's your
name Britney hey Britney this is like a
bucket list thing I can like checkoff
today um so I have like a I had a life
event that happened in April and someone
turned me on to you and it's been really
good ever since and sold my house put
all my money from my house into a
retirement fund I have no debt
thankfully never well except the house I
never had any debt and I'm finally like
really happy but I still have I boxed
everything up went away for a few months
and now I'm dealing with the boxes and
I'm living with a friend my friend is
really nice and I'm in his house and I
have a lot of kitchenware and I don't
need we don't need like two sets of
silverware and we don't need two sets of
pots and pans but eventually I'm not
going to live with my friend so I'm an
ENTJ so I think about things
obsessively it's ridiculous I think
sometimes some of my friends are like I
think you'll be okay but I just it you
know you get it oh yeah so right now
what I'm really struggling with is this
really nice set of like pots and pans
that I wanted so bad and now I don't
really need them and I don't know if
I'll really need them later so I don't
do I hold on to them and just think that
maybe I'll need them in a year or so
when I have my own place or I don't know
so so first off congratulations I'm
really really happy for you're in a
really great place right now and you
have some interesting problems that
aren't very big problems but they're
still they're better problems and and
you've moved into a world of better
problems so congratulations for that
what I'll say is you need to figure out
what the word
eventually means yeah because you said I
want to eventually move out and because
if it's eventually means a week from now
then yeah you probably don't want them
to get rid of those pots and pans right
but if eventually means I don't know
maybe someday then then yeah I would
decide that let them go because here's
the other thing that I just noticed from
the very end of your statement is
they're kind of they're just pots and
pans they might be nice but you don't
want them to be too precious
if something is too precious for me I
try to figure out a way to let it go
right that was good
so I picked the answer it's good bidding
oh man um do you have like you said
maybe a year is that is that where
you're at right now well I recently went
backpacking by myself and so now I'm
thinking that maybe I'll want to keep
backpacking so my eventually might
actually be never but I'm still trying
to work my way around if that's actually
gonna happen or if it's just my like gut
reaction to do something and not just
say I'm gonna do something no that's
yeah so yeah I was really just trying to
stall to come up with a answer no I uh
if that's the case like just get rid of
the pots and pans I mean if you want to
go backpacking you could also like find
friends and family who maybe could use
some pots and pans or you know find it
like yeah you know and like give it to
them with the the pretense of like I
might need this in five years I just
want to let you know I'm gonna go
backpacking across the world but when I
come back no I I guess my pet the answer
would be one day or day one you decide
thank you
all on you mr. Becker well I had a great
answer until that amazing pithy sentence
I once had someone email me and they
these are the short answers you start
with a long answer and if you can't do
her short one will tweet okay I once I
wanted someone email me and she said hey
I'm all into minimalism but help me
figure something out if I have an extra
set of China in the basement what's the
big deal I'm like huh it's actually a
pretty good question what is the big
deal
it took me a few days and and I finally
wrote back and I and I said look if all
you have in your basement is an extra
set of China then it's probably not a
big deal the problem is we have so much
more than one extra set of China in our
basements we have boxes and boxes of
stuff and more and more stuff and then
then this is when it becomes a burden to
us so if it's just if it's a one and a
half inch cross right like like this
isn't burdening your life if it's one
set of pots and pans it's probably not
burdening your life is it I got the pots
and pans but there's actually four or
five other boxes full of things and
that's the real issue then then that
might be it might be another question
but it's gonna be a year and if you have
the financial resources to buy pots and
pans when you get back in a year there's
man there's probably plenty of families
in Phoenix right now that would be
greatly blessed by those by those pots
and pans so that might be another way
that I'd be thinking it through yeah
thank you thank you yeah so true I was
thinking Ryan you you helped out a lot
of refugees and I know it's sort of like
the number one thing that they would ask
for like how do I get pots in pit lane
they first move move in because they
gotta be able to cook and it's not
something we often think about we think
about donating clothes and and you know
different household items but quite
often forget about these these basic
necessities people gonna use three times
a day quite often yeah it's it's crazy
too like helping out like I remember the
first family that I helped out there is
this was in Missoula Montana and there's
a wonderful organization there that that
it's it's like the IRC which I can't
really International Refugee Committee
or counts it's one of those anyway they
partner with this with this other
nonprofit and basically when the
refugees show up they go to this
nonprofit called soft landing you know
before before before we got on the stage
today Ryan said I gave you the weakest
chair cuz you're the lightest good luck
I knew I was a good that would've broke
on me in like two seconds so they go to
soft landing and my D which I just
stopped what's the worst that could
happen long story short they will get
all this stuff that they need and and
Missoula Montana is such a high culture
per capita there and there's so many
people there who just want to give and
they will just give as much as possible
it got to a point like after the first
six weeks where that family they were
like no more stuff we have plenty of
stuff thank you like if food they would
take for sure but yeah it's it was just
funny watching them go from literally
like I'm just packing up my car full of
pots and pans and blankets and coats and
boots and everything that they would
need when they moved to a you know cold
place from a very warm place and like
I'm bringing this into their home and
I'm
my I'm not gonna sit here like I don't
know if you need all this stuff I mean
let me tell you about minimalism you
know just all I can do is support them
as much as possible but to watch them go
from like just really just grabbing all
the free stuff that they could and then
transitioning to like okay no more it
was it was pretty interesting I mean let
me just add we found two local charities
when we were minimizing in Vermont
the Vermont refugee resettlement program
that took so many of our housewares and
all the things that you're mentioning
the care net pregnancy center in
downtown Burlington that was helping my
daughter was too and we were done having
children but we had all the baby and the
maternity stuff left over and and we
just found supporting those
organizations to be very motivating in
our in our minimizing journey and it's
it's the one thing that I tell people
you know should I sell it should I
donate it I'm like if you don't need the
money
which most of us don't I'm like find a
local charity whose mission you believe
in because generosity is not only the
result of minimalism in our lives but in
many ways generosity becomes the
lifeblood of it and very much a
motivating factor to get rid of our
things as our excess becomes a blessing
to others that's beautiful howdy
James Michelle and we met outside and I
was fangirling you totally nervous AF
right now and I'm shaking Phoenix and
I'm happy you guys are here you kind of
look like Jesus Ryan and live
we have crosses for sale out the lobby
just one one inch cross so my question
is I'm a vegan for ethical reasons and
the thing I'm facing is you know you
want to buy quality stuff not buy three
pairs to one pair of leather shoes for
example or a purse or whatever the case
is sure I'm buying more vegan stuff but
I have to replace it more vegans who
just got my vegan tattoos so it's
stamped so anyway so my thing is you
know I want to have just that one pair
of black booties or you know the one
black leather or non leather bag that's
gonna last me and it hasn't so what kind
of what do you recommend
with respect to what booties I just I'm
happy where I come from that means
something different so the short boots
so like I know Ryan I know that you were
trying to go vegan I think for a while
and then I think oh no I was vegan oh no
John Oh Josh he calls me up one day and
he's like I'm thinking about doing this
this vegan diet and I'm like what's a
vegan diet and he said oh don't worry
about it you would never be able to do
it and I said okay I'll call you back
so then I looked it up and I'm like I
could do this there's so many delicious
vegan things I can still eat so I called
Josh back and I was like dude I'm in and
I'll do it longer than you do and I did
I've totally won the bet he still owes
me a dollar but no it's it is it was a
very interesting like 12 or 13 months
the reason why I went back it was it was
I I would go on a date
and like me having to order I felt like
the girl at the Tate Lake I just really
felt like um does this have like honey
in it early you know I was thinking
right I wonder how Ryan could piss off
the vegans and the feminists today no I
just I I really I really am gonna stop
talking now
so so here's what I recommend to you
many III like to support
I like to support I I don't only support
local businesses you'll see all these
these you know stickers and and window
signs say buy local and I occasionally
see something to say buy local first and
that that tends in we can all we can
define local differently right I think
one of the big advantages of buying
things that are made in the United
States not only are you are you
supporting a local or national economy
and your dollar does go farther in those
local economies but you also you also
can be assured that you're the high
quality goods that you're buying weren't
made in a sweatshop if I had the option
I would certainly buy a maid iPhone I
would find a way to spend more money on
on that than a iPhone that I wasn't sure
whether or not it was made a thickly and
so I mean I think first we because the
reason that you are a vegan is because
of your morals with respect to animals
we also have to think of our ethics with
respect to to people as well right and
and so I want to keep both in mind and
so the one thing that I try to do is I
will support things locally and I buy
high quality goods most of the things
that I own are going to be either vegan
or vegan friendly and whether it's like
the pants I buy from a place called
Mission workshop or or different shirts
that I buy you know what I find is I
tend to buy things that are made locally
or at least in the United States and
that will last a long time
and it's gonna it's gonna take some it's
gonna it's gonna take some time to to
find the right place but that's the
beauty of minimalism for me like once I
find the thing that there works for me
then the I no longer have that that
paradox of choice because I've already
made the decision so right now you're in
this sort of exploring stage you need to
find high quality goods that are going
to last a long time it's probably going
to mean certain synthetic materials but
once you've found once you've found the
the once you've made your decision then
you don't have to keep making the same
decision over and over and which is what
consumerism tries to get us to do with
with the 52 shopping seasons every
single year right it's a I bought a new
so so here's a staff for you 90% of you
have purchased a piece of clothing
within the last 90 days
I'm sorry within the last 30 days 50% of
you have purchased something within the
last week I'm in that first category I
bought underwear it recently hypocrite
I've tried this experiment I thought we
shared underwear are you wearing them
today no I thought you were ladies and
gentleman Joshua Becker I might send you
to a website I'm familiar with reddit at
all but I know there's a there's a
subreddit called buy it for life and so
I would just maybe Google reddit ret di
T reddit buy it for life which would
probably send you to this forum and you
could ask any specific question about
hey I'm looking for the highest quality
this and if someone would knows you
might they might have a good
recommendation for you thank you
beautifully well we we didn't have any
pity answers for you so let's do one
more lightning round question how do you
what's your name hi I'm Jenny I'm from
Sweden which is not in California
then why do you have that New Jersey
accent oh I'm just joshing you what's
your question
okay so I often find myself in you know
dialogues about why and how minimalism
and some people just tell me that yeah
it's fine for me to be a minimalist but
you know that everyone cannot be a
minimalist because then no one would
shop meaning we need to close down all
of the shopping malls all of the stores
which will create very boring cities it
will create many people losing their
jobs getting you know poor miserable way
so so sorry
so I think Phoenix would be much less
boring if we could if we got rid of some
of the strip malls men it would I would
be so bored if I didn't see another
strip mall I was taking uber over here
and he was like you wouldn't believe how
many Walmart's are here and and I think
that's sort of the the the epitome of
this like convenience culture and the
answer your question is minimalist
aren't opposed to buying stuff you know
I'm not up here in a loincloth right I
think we all need some stuff the the the
question is what's the appropriate
amount and do I think if everyone in the
entire world became a minimalist
overnight that the economy would crash
yeah probably but do I think that's
gonna happen no III don't and so what
we're trying to do is effect change over
a long period of time
and I think what you're gonna see is the
economy shift from from an ownership
economy to access and service economy we
still spend money but we spend money on
more meaningful experiences
that's pithy that's good
I saw I saw Becker he wanted to
interject there what's that I looked
like you wanted to interject oh of
course
always you're right you're right I I
think when you become minimal as it
doesn't mean that you stop spending
money it means that you stop buying
stuff that you don't need oftentimes so
that you have money for something else
man I've been to Sweden I've been to
your your beautiful capital and man you
know what makes Stockholm beautiful
isn't isn't all the shopping malls it's
all the museums I mean what what an
amazing culture an amazing city and all
the experiences that you can enjoy there
and so the economy sure probably hiccups
probably shifts but I think it become
more of a service based economy more of
an experience based economy more of an
economy where we're doing good for other
people so I think that you just find it
you find the economy shifting rather
than collapsing and that doesn't sound
boring to me at all
no no I'll add that well first off
anyone who says well if everyone became
minimalist overnight well you know the
businesses was closed and the economy's
crashed more retail business is closed
last year than any other year there are
there are malls like the malls are
getting ready to take a huge hit this
year so not everyone's a minimalist and
that that stuff is still happening
so especially you look at 2008 that's
what happens when we spend too much then
the economy crashes so yes your friends
right if people stop spending money
tomorrow the economy crashes but when we
spend too much the economy crashes and
what I like to think is that minimalism
it brings a balance between too much and
too little
thank you thank you
I hold there real quick we're gonna move
on to another segment real quick called
added value so we talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently and since we are in Arizona by
the way we we just moved to LA but we
were considering places to move and I
could tell you the Arizona was actually
in the top three and it's not just
because Joshua Becker's here but no we
just love the whole state and and so I
can tell you that whether it's you know
if you need access to a big city and all
the amenities of a big city actually I
think it's easier in many ways to be a
minimalist in a big city because you
have access to things that you don't
have to own which is which is really
nice whether that's a rideshare service
or or all these other services and plus
we all have that now with you know we
have a million different songs in our
pocket and but we're seeing that with
physical goods as well and a large city
allows us to have access to more things
or a place like Tucson its Tucson in the
house tonight
anyone from Tucson yeah and so that
that's the place that we were we were
really thinking heavily about going
there's something magical about about
the City of Tucson and then the place I
want to recommend the place to add has
added value to my life and I sadly
haven't been there in a few years and
we're gonna get back there hopefully
next spring is Sedona Arizona here's the
weird thing about I know there are many
people from other parts of Arizona who
have never been there as I've talked to
them I just like me I I this is a weird
analogy I've never been I grew up in
Dayton Ohio for the first 31 years of my
life I never went to Cleveland
but Cleveland's the opposite of Sedona
but it's Sedona is literally the most
beautiful place I've ever been and I've
been a lot of places and so if you
listen to this at home or if you're just
in Arizona and you've never made the
trip there go there and Oh his first
time I forgot food poisoning was in
Jerome Arizona so
you can avoid the hamburgers there I've
got two recommendations um I forget the
restaurant
I met someone there at the restaurant is
it blue adobe's how what it's going yes
okay yeah it's like two months on the
street I just like just googled like
delicious tacos and they came up but I
was I was really impressed so check that
place out and then cartel oh my god like
I I've discovered cartel back in 2014
when Josh and I were on that crazy 100
city tour and like I still will like you
can order their coffee online and have
it shipped and I will do that every once
in a while it is yeah cartel is an
awesome coffee place if you haven't been
and you like coffee
you should go mr. Becker what do you and
your family like to do around the
beautiful Phoenix area Oh dad's value to
your life oh heavens I was gonna mention
that I was in Warsaw Poland last weekend
and totally had my life changed
speaking on minimalism there and just a
very fascinating country war-torn came
out of communism in 1989 the man I had
dinner with my age grew up looking out
the window at bread lines and now
they've been capitalist and Western
democratic country for the past 25 years
and it was it was very fascinating being
in that space
seeing them appreciate all the freedom
and entrepreneurial opportunities that
they had in their life and yet being
able to speak about minimalism and just
this whole idea of what what do we use
our freedom for I'm all for capitalism
I'm just all for using freedom and
entrepreneurial spirit for the for the
right things and man it was it was a
life-changing trip I think regardless of
the conversations I had just just being
there so that and we like to play soccer
with my kids down the street so
all right you a quick interruption if
you want to listen to our bonus episode
this week as well as all of our past
bonus episodes head on over to the
minimalists dot-com and click donate at
the top of our website
each week we publish the minimalists
private podcast exclusively for our
patreon supporters this private podcast
shows up in your normal podcast feed
like Apple podcasts overcast Google Play
or whatever podcast app you use and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show alright
before we wrap this up I want to thank a
few people where I think Sean and Jess I
don't want to thank them again because
we we thank them enough
no I'm just kidding we were on the road
with him right now and it'd be really
difficult to do to do it without them
we used to do it without them and it was
just me and Ryan sleeping on readers
floors and occasionally at rest stops in
our tour bus his Toyota Corolla in fact
I remember waking up in and I rest up
here in Arizona and I we had we had
slept you know maybe four hours with the
seats reclined and the Sun was coming up
and we were parked right in front of a
sign that said beware of venomous snakes
right there at the rest stop so that was
sort of our life for a while but now we
even have a hotel room to go back to
tonight which is really great but Shawn
and ingests are really grateful that you
decided to spend some time on the road
with us and let's give them a round of
applause I gotta tell you we go to a lot
of different venues sometimes they're
like heavy-metal rock venues which can
be interesting
and then sometimes they're really
awesome theaters like this one how about
a round of applause for the Mesa Arts
Center
and I just want to acknowledge Josh
Rebecca really quick I want to thank you
for doing what you do man
I think you're contributing to a lot of
people's lives I know you certainly
contributed to mine and a whole lot of
others and we're really grateful you
decided to spend some time with us here
tonight thank you so much thank you for
the invitation and if you leave here
tonight with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
y'all thank you so much Phoenix thank
you very much this is Ashley from West
Palm Beach Florida and I have a comment
and suggestion for those with the fear
of missing out specifically those in
their 20s and early ages so it comes to
concert a lot of times and pretty much
every time you can work a concert and
get your ticket for free this includes
music festivals and a lot of times you
even get behind the scenes and backstage
access and contact with the band so in
the end not only do you save money but
you have some very amazing experiences
and make new friends hi my name is
Daniel and I live in Charlotte North
Carolina
in previous podcasts I've heard people
wanting to do more for the environment
but not knowing how they can contribute
I've been using the search engine called
eco Ziya that's the letter e c.o s i
a.org ecozy org the search engine plants
trees with its ad revenue and while I do
agree that advertisement sucks to me
it's a small inconvenience to pay for a
great contribution for searches I'd be
doing anyway on the internet they have
already planted over 17 million trees
across the globe and they post monthly
video updates on YouTube hey this is
nori in West Orange New Jersey
responding to Andrew at your Denver tour
stop who is the leader of the minimalist
group there and feels like he's a
failure or doesn't live up to where some
the others in the group are on their
minimalism journey in addition to the
suggestion to lower your expectations
and raise your standards I also think
you should consider changing your
vocabulary instead of being the leader
of the group why not call yourself
something else like the facilitator or
the contact person it signifies that
you're the one who gets the rope
together and schedules when and where
you'll meet but they are also part of
the group you may feel better about
yourself and your role when you don't
feel like as the leader you should have
all the answers for your followers
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes or two
[Music]
you